i uncovered a fraud worth four billion
dollars there's an fbi investigation
lawsuits and a lot of influencers i
still have unfortunately
the worst coin that ever existed safeway
this is the story of safe moon a crypto
coin that millions of people hold and
some believe is here to change the world
it's more than just talking about a
store of value which wasn't the focus
it's more about building the future and
building a safe future and bringing it
now but what if they're wrong i've been
working with a small team to investigate
safemen for almost a year now and what
we've uncovered is shocking secret
payments i believe you got to pay off
and went away deleted evidence it's a
true
fbi operation here redacted everything
and hundreds of millions of dollars that
appears to have been stolen provably on
the blockchain welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host coffee zilla
let's get into it
are you sure this is smart i mean this
isn't the small fries you used to go
after yeah i know this is a billion
dollar company i i know you're accusing
some of these people of actual crimes
look i know do you
do you know there's risks to messing
with money like this this isn't a game
anymore okay fine if you really think
it's so irresponsible of me how about we
flip for it heads i go through with the
video tales i don't
this is a story of greed bad financial
decisions and somehow gambian wind farms
the creators of safe moon are now being
sued and investigated by the fbi but
before we get to that we have to discuss
how did this all start who creates coins
like safe moon was it a crypto
mastermind like soulja boy or garyvee
no it turns out it was a guy who
believes in q yes that q his name is
kyle and very little is known about him
other than he distrusts the government
and thinks they're a bunch of criminals
which um i don't know fair enough i
guess but kyle's not gonna complain
about it like most people and i think he
decided at some point if you can't beat
him you might as well join him and he
decides getting into crypto is the
perfect way to start redistributing some
of that wealth back to himself and
that's when he starts making a bunch of
points coins like give me your money
token really classy stuff you know but
for some reason this really wasn't
working out for him until kyle found
something called b token now when kyle
invested in b token he liked that it had
a special property to it a five percent
tax on every transaction which was then
split into two parts three percent was
added back to the liquidity pool and two
percent was distributed to all the
holders of b which just encouraged
people not to sell you just held and
made money and kyle liked this idea a
lot which is why soon after he copied
the code and launched it himself but
with a few changes he raised the tax to
10 percent and he changed the name to
something
a lot more catchy he called it safe moon
and he promised everyone from the
beginning no rug is possible join us on
our journey safely to the moon now just
so you understand in the world of meme
coins safe moon basically translates to
easy money safe money it's like setting
the world's most delicious cheese on the
world's most obvious trap which is why
of course
everyone fell for it look i appreciate
your concern but
somebody has to do this there are
literally millions of people who are
invested in safemen and those millions
are going to hate you for it you think
anyone who is in safe moon is going to
be grateful for your story they're going
to be pissed coffee and not at the
people who lied to them but at you for
telling them the truth and the
probability of you coming out ahead
is
unlikely
that's all i'm saying yeah you're
probably right but you're gonna do it
anyways
yeah you humans are so confusing
savemen immediately went viral because
of the promise of safe easy money and
kyle pretty clearly wasn't ready for it
people who knew him say kyle kind of
didn't think this stupid plan would
actually work hi i'm james i was a
senior moderator for safe moon
kyle told me that he had no idea safeman
was going to explode like it did his
expectation was that he would be in and
out that's right he was expecting to be
in and out and i only can imagine how he
probably thought to himself how can
people be falling for this but clearly
they were and kyle decided he may need
to hire some people at this point to
help him out but when it did take off he
wasn't prepared he had to bring in
people really fast and he did kyle hired
a bunch of people almost as unqualified
as himself there's a guy thomas smith
who became the lead developer he's a
grown man who insists everyone call him
papa i'm your papa i'm the uh totally
dev here now after papa a guy named john
caroni is brought on as the ceo of safe
moon and he turns out to be the guy in
the group project that sort of everyone
ends up hating their argument had always
been oh we brought john on in you know
the heat of the moment because we needed
to it was an emergency we're so sorry
for bringing him in and he ruined the
project there's also a bunch of people
hired at this time that you're not going
to need to know till later so we're just
going to ignore them for now but here
they are on screen this was just all
thrown together in the heat of the
moment call it what you want the
incompetent avengers the league of
extraordinarily stupid gentlemen either
way it kind of worked in their favor for
the following reason it is hard to tell
when safe moon is malicious and when it
is stupid there just is a problem with
that and there's reasons for that which
we can get into later you see that's
bootsy one of the researchers i worked
with and you can tell he's sort of been
hit by this smoke screen of stupidity
that safe moon has created like here's a
guy who's been researching safe moon for
11 months alongside strider and myself
and we're all still baffled people just
can't figure out how something this dumb
made
this much money so we have a valuation
around three to four billion dollars and
we did this all in nine months so i
almost helped them in a way how dumb it
was and people were buying like crazy
because who doesn't want easy safe money
and you know who actually loves easy
save money more than anyone influencers
this is all in april 2021 that's when
statement really exploded in popularity
they had billboards across the nation
they had the biggest influencers talking
about them
not that it was free of criticism
unfortunately this is a giant ponzi
scheme those were just the haters that
needed to be destroyed by the safe moon
army that by the way is the name safe
mooners gave themselves and they
declared war on the haters here's one of
many of these safe moon soldiers we are
the safe moon army and i am safe moon
soldier i didn't get this tattoo for no
damn reason
nobody will ever silence me with threats
or threaten my money you know it's
almost embarrassing to watch a grown man
defend a token that was designed to rob
him of his money but maybe it's time to
talk about just that how safe moon was
designed we're going to talk about how
safe moon was supposed to be so safe
because that's really the point of all
this isn't it your money is supposed to
be safe and that idea came from this
claim about a locked liquidity pool but
what does that mean in d5 the way you
trade tokens is with something called an
lp liquidity pool every pool basically
has two different currencies and the
point of it is to provide buyers and
sellers a way to trade without regular
market makers like wall street has in a
liquidity pool the way it works is the
ratio of your two assets determines the
price for example one liquidity pool
might hold five thousand safe moon and a
thousand b paired together and the price
is just the ratio of these assets so
five to one in this case and i can trade
on either side of it i can sell safe
moon by putting safe moon into the pool
and getting b b out at that ratio or i
can buy safe moon by putting b b into it
and as people buy and sell this ratio
shifts and the price changes
automatically now the more liquidity you
have the bigger the pool is the better
because price stabilizes and i can feel
you all collectively yawning at this
point so we're gonna move on before we
put anyone to sleep but just know the
key innovation of safe moon was this
idea that every time someone trades you
just take five percent of it as a tax
and put it into the liquidity pool and
lock that money up so safe move the
company can't touch it that way you know
as an investor you can always trade safe
moon for a fair price this is how you
avoid the scam of how tokens commonly
get rug pulled where suddenly the price
or liquidity pool of a project would
collapse which happened all the time in
d5 with cases like this
so the market cap is 2.168
trillion
dollars and now the mark oh
oh
it went to zero
yeah
the whole pitch of safe moon is
basically look rug pulls like that
that's impossible with safe mode because
the money's locked up it's right there
in the read me it's autumn magically
locked up
or wait was it auto locking because i
kind of read that too well that's
probably the same thing
unless it wasn't locked at all uh oh
this is confusing safe moon appears to
be contradicting itself maybe we should
go to the ceo of safe moon so he can
explain it once and for all so the lp
lock is
automated not automatic automated and
automatic are not the same thing hmm
that didn't help well maybe maybe we go
to the source code that they copied from
b token and figure out what's really
going on here surely b token wasn't a
rug pull so we have
this b token code and b was kind of a
smaller rug pull
oh
well that's that's even worse how are we
getting out of this one fellas our big
difference you're gonna find that we're
never gonna rug uh oh i think we're
looking at a pinky promise protocol here
fellas but if b token could rug pool
that means the funds in safe moon are
also not locked up and are also
not really safe so that was kind of a
huge lie but surely this guy has the
best of intentions and won't have any
skeletons come out of his closet later
and incriminate him i said
knowing that i'm about to play a clip
let's not pretend why we're here
call this idea all the ideological like
let's
let's save the rockets then this is
about money
oh we're in a bit of trouble here aren't
we look guys
i'm not against money right i'm i'm
american so as i like money as much as
the next guy as long as the next guy is
in jake paul but you know this just
doesn't seem like a good deal at this
point especially when the founder
created a token called give me your
money but i get it look that's just my
opinion right we need evidence now and
so that's when i started looking at the
blockchain i started collecting all of
safe moons wallets and identifying them
and when i did i found that kyle had
already been rug pulling safe moon since
it started just more slowly than the b
token guys see on march 5th this shows
up on the blockchain as the function
remove liquidity which of course they
said was impossible and the first time
they took from the cookie jar it wasn't
for much only 14 000 was taken but it
added up over time and i worked with a
blockchain researcher to find out just
how much kyle took the total amount of
safe moon that came into kyle's wallet
was over 164 trillion tokens fast
forward to mid september to mid december
this grossed him just under 10.3 million
wow that's a lot of money for a token
that was never going to rug pull and
maybe that's why the fudge just seemed
like it wasn't stopping safe moon may
have been booming from influencers but
they're suffering from a major pr
problem known as
evidence and this is when a twitter
account called war on rugs first
appeared who started warning people that
quote the likelihood of losing all funds
was absolute with safe moon now this was
a pretty epic ownage of facts and logic
from war on rugs here and it seemed like
safe moon was on the ropes right up
until war on rugs decided to scam people
himself with his own drug bull
uh to which
yeah the only response is
like how the guy calling out scams
decided to scam people himself which as
you guys know um i would never do to you
pump the stockzilla and basically safe
moon was like aha well that guy's a
scammer so are we cool now everyone and
everyone was kind of like i i guess
we'll forget about it all he both seemed
to have pointed something out pretty
important about safe moon but then he
also turned out to be a real piece
and after a war on rugs the safe moon
army just really kind of rallied against
anti-scammers and they made it their
mission to expose the exposers with
people like this this channel will be
dedicated to exposing opportunists and
shillers of fud fud for those that are
new to the term stands for fear
uncertainty and doubt my mission is to
analyze and expose those that use fud to
manipulate you for their own personal
gain now i know what you're thinking
with rambo over here going seal team six
on all the haters safe moon must be
doing pretty well and it's true they
decided it was a good time to clear up
all the fud once and for all with a
smart contract audit today the safe moon
audit just dropped on our heads so that
happened except the auditors were like
yeah your code kind of sucks and there
are major vulnerabilities my favorite
quote is that they said mishandling it
can have devastating consequences to the
project to which safe moon was like oh
well you don't have to worry about that
because if if we took your money we'd
get sued and go to jail now of course
within a year of that
they would be sued and investigated by
the fbi but we're getting ahead of
ourselves safe moon even for all its
hype just really still had problems
internally like people are leaving the
company everything is kind of a mess and
maybe that's why at some point the
ownership of safe moon was transferred
over to papa and just so you guys
understand the safe moon community just
like worship this guy here's an example
this guy says papa's literally a genius
xrp offered him 2 million to work with
them and he denied it any blockchain
project would die to have pop on their
team and papa says like truth now later
the xrp team would reply that they had
no idea who papa was and had never heard
of them but the point is the safe moon
people thought papa was the
reincarnation of satoshi nakamoto and
that he was gonna usher safe moon into a
golden age of prosperity and now did
that happen
no in reality papa just stole more money
like kyle did except he was a bit crafty
about it i guess like when kyle stole
money he just kind of took from the
liquidity pool but papa was different he
had a story about it he justified
himself by saying he wasn't rug pulling
liquidity he was moving the funds in a
fund migration from a version one
liquidity pool to a version two and as
they told it it was for the people's
benefit in fact every time papa migrated
these funds he would send the same memes
every time
boom
but behind all the boomer memes not all
the money made its way over and you
might not be surprised to find out that
some of it found its way into papa's
pockets we first find a hint of this on
may 12th when he says i migrated the lp
in a way i figured everyone would love
but here's what actually happened i'm
going to visualize what papa should have
done versus what he actually did what
was supposed to happen in a migration is
that he would move the b and b safe moon
pair from v1 to v2 simple right
instead papa did something different he
took the b and b pair from v1 but kept
the safe moon and he only put the bmb
into the v2 pool with a purchase of safe
moon meaning papa got more safe moon
from the v2 contract as well now on the
surface this appeared to cause the price
to spike because a huge purchase order
was just made
but in reality papa was keeping gigantic
amounts of safe moon that he could later
sell for a personal profit and the value
of safe moon overall was falling once
again me and some researchers calculated
how much in dollars papa took and here's
what we found so thomas was true
liquidity 18 different times he actually
held on to 143 million dollars worth of
liquidity the sum of outgoing safe moon
transactions was about a hundred million
dollars of that hundred million fifty
eight point nine million dollars went to
bitmart and 8.1 million dollars went to
other undisclosed wallets i feel like i
need to remind everyone this is the same
guy who also said this our big
difference you're gonna find that we're
never gonna rug so i guess turns out
that was a big lie um and the money
wasn't safe after all but as with all
things safe moon things are about to get
much worse you have to understand safe
mode at this point was under a lot of
stress and the team was kind of
fracturing internally caroni in
particular was the most hated on the
team people didn't like how he wanted to
run things and here's one of safe moon's
own developers hank wyatt blaming him
for a lot of safe moon's problems
that was an organized flood attack that
was only a small small amount of why the
red candles were happening john wouldn't
let us lock up a quarter of a billion
dollars in liquidity that's why all the
fun was
and when we asked him hey we don't need
this money we shouldn't touch it and he
said oh but we could still swim with it
and he wanted to run
the lp yeah he can lick my whole balls
now i know what you're thinking i
probably could have cut that last part
of the call and you still would have
gotten the gist
but you know i really think you have to
hear these people describe john caroni
in its full glory to understand just how
hated this guy was there's like no
substance of a human there anymore he's
just
he's just
john's a [ __ ] monster and does not
care about his employees whatsoever i
this is going to sound really dumb and i
apologize in advance the only time i
like john is when he's depressed
see now you get the picture basically no
one liked caroni and this rift only
escalated with operation phoenix first
signs of this was when john started
talking about project phoenix which he
then changed to project phoenix because
he spelled it wrong and refused to admit
that he just made a spelling error and i
have no idea why but it will haunt me to
the end of my life because he literally
could have just
switched it and instead he is running
with it to this day we're fast
approaching our full unveil of operation
phoenix but he starts talking about
project phoenix the rest of the team
doesn't talk about it at all which
didn't seem like much of the time
until later on when we get the leaked
audio can you explain what the operation
phoenix is nobody can explain what
operation phoenix is including
john operation phoenix is is a little
bit of a journey but it's mainly a bunch
of
different complex things coming together
uh to create an evolution he has a lot
of claims of what it can be or what it
could be it started out as banking the
unbanked in africa the most overused
phrase by anyone who has a lot of money
in the crypto space talked about how it
was going to be utilized as a currency
in the gambia then it became about
windmills
uh and clean energy then it became about
burning tokens with those windmills
somehow the phrase every turn a burn
became a thing for a while nano
technology was used at one point
according to them i can't go any farther
that truly i'll just keep rambling about
it it's a gobbledygook it makes no sense
so to summarize john is off doing
whatever project phoenix is and he wants
to use the safe moon war chest to fund
it meanwhile the core team kind of hates
jon they resent him but they can't kick
him out because he's the ceo so instead
they decide to start a new project they
call it piggy bank token uh so the idea
of piggy appeared to just be
their next attempt to do whatever it is
the team wanted to do
without jon
that was another example of the rift
that seemed to have been created now
piggy would turn out to be a big failure
in the months ahead but the anti-caroni
team decided they weren't going to leave
safe moon quietly many of them wanted
their cut of the pie hank wyatt for
instance wanted a three million dollar
severance package his best interest is
to give me my three million dollar
severance package his big plan was to
use his ownership over safe moon's
various social platforms as leverage
kind of forcing his hand on that one
because i also own the twitter but this
bad attempt at blackmail sort of
backfired on hank when this audio call
leaked and hank was basically just
kicked out immediately the whole team
would eventually be replaced as well as
carony realized what had happened with
piggy but i started to wonder was it
just hank looking for a payout do you
think thomas kyle these guys basically
got paid off
to not become like permanent enemies of
safe moon believe that kyle
we had a discussion
in legal discussions with their lawyers
about suing safe moon to regain control
thomas said that he'll honor whatever
kyle agrees to one of the things that
they were going to ask for was to be
paid to go away essentially i'll sue you
for all this fraud and all these things
and you will very possibly have criminal
charges and then he gets a payoff i
believe he got a payoff and went away
because it just disappeared he never
said a word to us about what what
happened
[Music]
well those are quite the allegations but
in order to understand whether they're
credible we need to start talking about
john caroni all right so hey i'm john
i'm the ceo of safe moon we already know
most people didn't like him but we're
gonna take our own look at him and
decide for ourselves caroni's past is
mostly military he worked for the
department of defense and his parents
are both former cia and it's clear from
the beginning that he wanted to run a
much different safe moon than the other
guys he saw himself as something of a
tech visionary and he saw safe moon as
the vehicle for that he said safe moon
was a technology company we're a
nine-month-old blockchain innovation
company a tech company they were gonna
build products like a crypto wallet and
yes gambian wind farms and it wasn't
until september 2nd that crony would
truly get his chance to fulfill this
vision he was already ceo but a lot of
people were struggling with him for
power and for influence but after the
piggy bank token disaster crony really
got the chance to clean house and he was
about to get his chance in the driver's
seat now when most people talk about
visionaries you think of elon musk or
steve jobs but everyone forgets that 99
of visionaries are just all talk first
they think you're crazy then they fight
you and then all of a sudden you change
the world and caroni basically fits this
second model he talks a big game but he
kind of lacks the track record let's
start with the gambian wind farms
remember that this is that project
phenix thing we heard so much about
welcome safewood army and the wider tech
audience to your operation phoenix
reveal let's start with wind we've given
you a lot of teasers regarding the wind
turbines but here are the details the
use of wind power has proven viable and
just as small plane wings have evolved
over the years
so can the physical designs of turbine
now wait a second i know what you're
thinking that wind turbine it looks
pretty good actually and that's because
it's someone else's wind turbine a
company called symtiv made it here's the
actual ceo
this is nemo and a small scale wind
turbine to generate simple affordable
and reliable wind energy i don't know
about you but the fact that safe moon
didn't build the technology in their
tech demo seems like a bit of an issue
but here at safe moon an issue
is just an excuse to innovate so what
was that innovation well if you can get
past phd level word salad basically they
put little dots on the windmill and
claim to make it more efficient which uh
gonna need to see some evidence for that
one fellas and safe moon's other
technologies aren't much better safe
moon launched their own crypto wallet
which was supposed to replace the
popular trust wallet app the only issue
is it seems to be a one-to-one
uh copy of the trust wallet but now it
has the safe moon logo on it and has the
safeman colors and all this is right in
line with safe moon's business practices
from the very beginning when they took b
token renamed it and called it a big
innovation or
sorry uh they called it an evolution
safe move is the evolution safe moon is
the evolution create an evolution and
you have to be willing to evolve
but now that we've talked about safe
moon's contributions to technology
we need to talk about the one thing they
did that does seem original and that's
the v2 contract of safe moon see safe
moon was still getting flack for being
the clone of a rug pull so they decided
they were going to upgrade it now mind
you this is different from like the v2
liquidity pool we talked about papa
migrating to this is an actual upgrade
of the token itself unsurprisingly this
upgrade would turn out to be a total
disaster the big differences for version
two were really the changed fees instead
of a 10 tax split two ways there were
now four different uses of the fees as
well as a switch to a proxy contract but
the big question became how do you get
everyone to switch over to this v2 token
they didn't want to split their
community so they decided to force
people to switch using a hundred percent
tax
what could go wrong the big one is
regarding the 100 tax
yeah so basically we had to we were
shutting down v1 so yes they raised
their tax of safe moon from 10
to 100 in an attempt to make the v1
token useless and force everyone to
migrate their tokens over to v2 where
it's actually usable the problem of
course is that a lot of people who
invest in safe moon aren't tech savvy
and when you send money on safe moon
with this 100 tax which you can do
you get completely wiped out essentially
if you tried to do anything but migrate
your
tokens to v2 you would lose all of your
tokens where'd it go hey news flash safe
moon and anybody else out there it
shouldn't be that complicated now it
turns out you can actually calculate how
much people lost in this safe moon v 100
tax thing
and here's what we found so the 100 tax
was implemented on december 29th after
summing up the incoming save moon at bnb
and its historical value the total loss
has added up to 102 million
wow a hundred million dollars and that
money it didn't go nowhere these lost
tokens they went to the liquidity pool
and we know who controls that john
caroni now it's worth saying that some
in safe moon said that they were going
to pay people back for these losses this
guy uh the fud hound who you saw earlier
real name ryan
he said that they were going to refund
people affected by v1 taxes two weeks
later ryan would resign or get fired
depending on who you believed ryan said
he felt forced to follow his code of
ethics caroni said he was fired for
breaching confidentiality maybe he just
said a little too much but i'm sure
losing one of your community figureheads
isn't that ominous i'm sure everything's
fine guys right honestly this is where
safe moon really goes from like kind of
a disaster to full on everything's
falling apart so it's gonna feel like
we're jumping around at times and i
apologize for that in fact i actually
forgot to mention we kind of skipped by
the fact that at this point the fbi had
actually started investigating safe moon
so you know there's that
hank was visited by the fbi at one point
asked about all of us i guess it says
something when an fbi investigation is a
side item that you're like oh yeah did i
mention that
uh and not only that things got worse of
course because calls leaked of former
safe moon members talking about deleting
evidence in case of an fbi investigation
you also got to be careful because if
they believe that you delete it out of
content to you know hide evidence yeah
if you're deleting it before being
subpoenaed you're not deleting any
evidence of anything you're just
deleting your messages it's a true fbi
operation here redacted everything the
strategies seem to be you know delete
evidence before they tell us not to
delete evidence which we'll see how that
works out for them although we may not
have to wait that long because soon
after this a class-action lawsuit was
filed against safe moon the creators of
safe moon and all the influencers who
promoted it were all accused of pumping
and dumping the coin and frankly when
you look at the 97 pages of evidence it
does seem pretty overwhelming like i
said at this point things were just
falling apart and while crony would
usually use this time to pivot to some
new harebrained scheme he had cooked up
his interviews started to go a little
differently there are a group of people
who accuse safe moon of false and
misleading statements and
not having the liquidity behind the
currency
are you talking to your community are
you just hoping they all go away
yikes that's probably not how he thought
that was gonna go now caroni gives the
stock response of course again we won't
comment on an ongoing case but uh safe
moon will continue mission we'll
continue moving forward but you have to
wonder what their play is here safe moon
is down 90
and almost everyone has abandoned ship
i still have unfortunately
the worst coin that ever existed safe
moon i came on this show i bought
thousand dollars of it and i now have
two thousand left so and at this point
john corony is really sort of the last
one standing he's the last one left and
i'm sure the most relevant question many
people have at this point is like this
okay look kyle took money we get it papa
took money fine the v2 robbed people of
millions of dollars okay maybe they'll
one day pay that back karoni sucks as a
boss fine they're getting sued okay
actually none of this is okay but the
question is is caroni actively profiting
from safe moon the way kyle and papa did
is he
misappropriating the lp as i'm writing
this this is still the sentiment in safe
moon's discord these people still
believe the great john caroni would
never do anything sketchy quote i can't
imagine him doing anything unethical
with the pool of money so now we're
going to shift gears and take a look at
that is caronie the hero who kicked out
all the bad apples is he an out of touch
visionary who bites off more than he can
chew or is he something else as i
started my investigation the first thing
i realized with caroni is that he
behaves differently than kyle and papa
he doesn't move liquidity around as much
but it's clear he's getting the money
from somewhere after all he claims safe
moon had 90 employees so where did the
money come from to pay for all these
people naturally i asked around they're
paid to be on
par
all right according to ginger bitmart is
the source of new funds allegedly
bitmark by the way is an exchange like
coinbase and they were one of the first
to list safe moon on their exchange but
the answer you just heard that safe moon
is being paid to list on bitmart didn't
sound right to me so i asked bitmart via
email and they replied that they weren't
paying safe moon
it was the other way around
quote safe moon paid bitmart to be
listed so then the question is how is
safe moon making millions from bitmar
because we know they are recently an
employee came forward anonymously and
told me that after safe moon signed the
bitmart deal quote john said to us that
he was going to put us all in a new tax
bracket although this person says they
never saw any of that money so again the
question is not if safe moon was making
tons of money but how they were doing it
since they weren't being paid to be
listed i had to dig in deeper so i
started to look at the way things worked
on bitmart because it was a little bit
different see bitmart artificially
implemented tokenomics the way safe moon
always had with a 10 percent tax however
the way bitmart did it was slightly
different normally five percent of each
transaction would go directly to the
liquidity pool but bitmark did it
slightly differently quote five percent
will be returned to the developers to be
added back to the liquidity pool for
safe moon tokens so instead of sending
the fees directly to the lp they sent it
to safe moon's developers to do it but
go with me here what if the money never
made it there what if bitmart sent those
fees to safe moon to put in the lp and
they just kept it that would be pretty
damning wouldn't it but the question is
how do we find out for sure if this
theory is correct and this is when i
realized i needed coroni's wallets to
figure out if he was getting large
payments from bitmart and what he was
doing with them because bear in mind
corny was not a rich man before safe
mode so if he's getting millions of
dollars from bitmart we know why the
problem is caronie was the most clever
of all of these guys at hiding his
wallet caroni is like a ghost i didn't
have anything on him so to figure this
out i knew i'd have to dig deeper than i
ever had before i started by trying to
talk to people who had worked for safe i
knew one of them would have seen
caronie's wallets right like or have
been paid by it and i just kind of had
to convince them to tell me what it was
now obviously most of the people i
talked to said well i can't talk maybe
they felt threatened or they felt like
they were under nda or they just didn't
want to be part of a piece fair enough
but eventually i found the right person
he said quote there's a lot of
information surrounding safe moon yes i
do have an nda regarding internal things
but a lot of things i've witnessed
aren't covered under that now this
person asked to remain anonymous for
obvious reasons because they felt
threatened before by some of the members
of safe moon and they wish to not repeat
that chapter of their lives but when i
got on the phone with this person they
were a gold mine they had direct links
to several of the team members and
provided two really important wallets in
particular the most notable were a kyle
wallet who's the creator of safe moon
and john caroni's secret wallet that
they've both been hiding and
they tell us a lot we're gonna start
with john caroni's alleged wallet which
is this the first thing we find is that
he was receiving massive payments of
tether totaling up to 15 million dollars
and where did these payments come from
from bitmark he also had four million in
safe moon this would all seem to confirm
the theory that the fees from bitmart
that were supposed to go to the lp
may have been used by caroni after all
he said the bitmart deal would put them
in a new tax bracket but in addition to
that i also saw something else which is
millions of dollars flowing from
caronie's wallet to a familiar address
not the liquidity pool but kyle the
creator of safe moon the one we had been
told had been paid off by caroni and
this all corroborates the information
that the ginger gave me earlier i
believe you got to pay off and went away
because it just disappeared he never
said a word to us about what what
happened not that this case is fully
settled we still have many questions
like what exactly was this three million
dollar payment to kyle for where did the
rest of the money from bitmark go i
reached out to john caroni about this
regarding this investigation for over a
month to see if he had any way of
explaining these problems he declined to
comment my opinion it may just be that
there is no good explanation for this
and cronie just wants to stay quiet but
the question is where does that leave us
the story of safe moon may not be over
but the winners and losers are basically
decided the winners are kyle papa and
caroni who all made millions of dollars
off this thing not to mention the
several safe moon insiders who we didn't
even have time to talk about today they
also got a cut and the influencers they
also got a cut basically everyone except
for the real believers in safe moon
won the real losers were the people who
held on to hope held on to the belief
that maybe if they just trusted this
this new fancy crypto thing they could
escape their dead-end job maybe they
felt stepped on by the system like kyle
used to feel only for them this time
they were just stepped on again just in
a new way in a new system created not by
governments or laws but by unregulated
financial markets the only real hope for
justice here is that regulators do what
they've been failing to do for so long
in the crypto space which is protect
consumers from fraud and ultimately i do
believe that's what's happened here
fraud i think you can get lost in
semantics in the stupidity smoke screen
that safe moon kicks up you know you can
get lost talking about the gambian wind
farms but ultimately the real story is
that safe moon said the funds were
automatically locked up your money is
safe and it wasn't they took the money
at the expense of the investors and
that's the story nope it's not enough oh
come on look at all the evidence i'm
telling you coffee evidence does not
matter you're exposing things people
don't want exposed
yeah maybe either way i'm just kind of
glad it's all over well now that that's
over let's give the people what they
really want i just got a hot lead on
will smith wait hold that thought
maxwell i just got a text from papa he
wants to talk oh brother you can't be
serious you're not really considering
this are you of course i am he could be
the final piece to all of this no he's
not i'm telling you they don't want to
know well i do and i'm taking this call
next time on coffeezilla
this feels like fraud this is fraud i
mean how how could it not be you guys
are millionaires your investors are down
90 and you guys are million millionaires
directly from a representation that was
false do you feel bad for all the safe
moon investors
have watched this coin that they loved
like plummet 90
yeah they do as as you should by the way
did you ever suspect coronia fraud
yes
i didn't i i never got a payout epic
never i'm sure we'll see this on netflix
someday